you know more than 50,000 people are
still not allowed to return home this
morning two days after explosions at a
chemical plant in southeastern Texas the
fire continues to burn important HS
firefighters are letting it burn out to
prevent even more explosions a decision
will be made today about lifting
mandatory evacuation orders Omar
Villafranca shows us how some families
returned home despite being told to stay
away for Thanksgiving I had to leave
without my dog because we were really
scared for our life
Annie Geist glare came home to grab
everything she left behind including her
beloved dog Louie after flames reporting
HS house Wednesday morning it was
literally blazing it wasn't that it was
blazing like you could feel the heat a
massive blast felt up to 30 miles away
tore through the tpc plant just after
midnight the impact blew indoors and
shattered windows across the area Don
and Diana playboy spent Thanksgiving
cleaning shards of glass from inside
their bedroom
despite the mandatory evacuation order
it's kind of scary but you got to do
what you got to do to protect your
property sometimes a second blast 13
hours after the first forced the
mandatory evacuation of about 60,000
people it won't be lifted until we're
comfortable or I'm comfortable that the
citizens are going to be safe coming
back in the plants owner has a history
of environmental issues it was fined
more than two hundred thousand dollars
in January for air quality violations
local officials are monitoring the air
the 24/7 monitoring has been carried out
in that all of that has shown that there
no contaminants in the air that are
harmful to human health Connie and Craig
play coy defied the order to make the
most of the holiday the fires are
getting smaller and they're getting
under control so we felt pretty
comfortable to come back and try to pull
it together and have dinner with all our
family for CBS this morning I'm Omar
Villafranca